going back to the topic of beds and
everything opinions on pajamas do any of
you guys wear pajamas i sleep naked
uh like specifically like pajamas yeah
just pajamas no for me it's just like
underwear and some random all right good
i don't understand pajamas at all uh
yeah
some people do you wear a t-shirt to bed
i don't wanna wear it why why would you
wear it
i mean unless it's like [ __ ] stinking
hot like in the summer like i'll wear no
shirt but
most of the time like max comfort is the
least amount of clothes you could wear
yeah basically
and like you know you basically only
wear boxes so your [ __ ] your [ __ ]
dangly bits don't go everywhere yeah
that's pretty much the only reason
freedom though you know
let them loose i'm sleeping i want to be
comfy no well i
like i don't know i like wearing a
t-shirt because sometimes in the morning
the weather can like completely change
so i don't especially nowadays in the
winter like
i'm a little bit too cold if i don't
wear at least the t-shirt even with the
even with the heater on yeah but yeah i
don't know
what about when you say like a friend's
house right do you what do you
do do you wear a t-shirt when you sleep
because i i'm just like immediately i'm
like right i'm stripping oh
it depends how close i am to that friend
really yeah i don't i mean doesn't
matter who they are i'm like right if
i'm staying in your house i'm sorry i'm
asleep
like i'll see what boxes on i'll humor
you i'll i won't get my junk everywhere
yeah i'll see what boxes are
you can just not wear a shirt i i can't
sleep with the t-shirt on why
why don't i feel like i'm outside still
you know
when i take the t-shirt off in my head
it signifies like okay we're going to
bed or i'm going in the back are you the
type of person who like when doing like
a serious like
heavy [ __ ] like you have to like take
your shirt off no
but but wait wait no i know people like
that go go go go go go go
you don't have anything like that
i had a few friends where like like if
the pain was like
really [ __ ] like it was such a
powerful [ __ ]
they'll be like to like fully get out
like a hundred percent of their power
where's the hidden camera no [ __ ] way
is this true i'm serious i'm serious
what do you think like [ __ ] goku with
weighted training
with weighted shirts or something you're
just like hold on let me use 100 of my
power to push this [ __ ] up yeah because
you're like sweating so hard you're just
like i need to take my shirt off but
like what if okay
the shits are terrible yeah yeah yeah so
you're like [ __ ] i mean i just woke up
i'm naked so [ __ ] it i'll do it when i'm
naked i'm not gonna lie
i've had moments where the shit's been
so like just powerful and stressful
where i'm just like i have to take my
shirt off
i i i don't do that but i know people
who do yeah i don't know if it's like
placebo but like it works
he's [ __ ] crying [ __ ] imagine like
[ __ ] tyler
on the [ __ ]
you know the only time i when i'm like
if i'm ever like vomiting i want to be
naked what
because i want to get that [ __ ] anywhere
i'll smell my clothes so i'm like
i'll just get like and i'll hug this
toilet bowl until i'm done but if you're
hugging it then like there's no way
you're going to [ __ ]
like onto your shirt i just don't want
that [ __ ] in my closet my clothes at all
man i'm like right i
don't know i just and also feels better
i don't know why i feel it like
i need to get i didn't get like it's so
restricted i'm getting stuffy and these
i just want to vomit like i don't know
like when i was
like did you vomit because every time
i've seen you vomit you have clothes
oh yeah yeah but like when i'm like you
know if you have like if you're really
sick you're like when i had food
poisoning
like whenever you know when they thought
i had the rona like i i was like
vomiting and i had to be like naked
because i was like otherwise i feel like
get on my clothes and i'm like that's
gross it's so funny little did you know
that during the chess tournament every
time you went to take a [ __ ] he'd just
[ __ ] rip off his suit
that was awful when i was starting the
[ __ ] with the suit on i'm like please
please don't get it on the suit that's
the worst timing to take a [ __ ] it's
when you're in a pool
[Applause]
because like for me wearing a t-shirt in
bed is just like
sometimes especially in the winter you
wake up and it's like a cold [ __ ]
morning
i love that and like how do you escape
your duvet at that point yeah
just it's it's like i don't know being
branded you're like just [ __ ] do it
no just do it
for me it's just like gravity has
increased tenfold yeah
it's like i'm like experiencing 10 g's
in this bed right now it's like
i actually can't get it it literally
takes me like an hour to get out of bed
i don't know i
have like the the [ __ ] call of duty
like text popping up my screen mission
get to the shower
like that's what it's like for me i have
to do like one limb at a time to be
like all right let me let me just get my
right arm out and once that's like room
temperature then i get my
right leg out it's like all right now i
can go but i used to have like a
heated thing that you could put under
your bed right but that just made me
lazier so i got rid of it
what do you mean because i never wanted
to leave
like a heated thing under the like
mattress it was like just always warm
but i was like
this is also a fire hazard uh and uh
yeah i just don't i i cannot get out of
bed with this thing
yeah that's true